[Musique]
nous sommes venus ici pour régler ce problème, nous ne
partirons pas tant que je ne le ferai pas Je pense que c'est
l'endroit le mieuxvenu qu'ils ne peuvent pas
arrêter de te voir en tête Je suis désolé,
recommençons d'accord, c'est comme si nous étions  les
deux seules personnes au monde que
je peux réparer ça pour vous
hey mrs.  Le voisin de Sutter Eko Eduardo
comment être un mec italien sexy c'est juste un
tour aller pour ce que l'
idiot de Jake Federico venait de me dire
sur votre principale dernière chose que vous devez
quitter en ce moment ce que plus d'amis
gagne ici la nuit dernière tu veux vraiment
ça, je ne fais tout simplement pas confiance à ce gars Ryan
[Music]
tu sais ce que je pensais de courir
la chasse
si tu as 18 ans, fais-le peut dire
et ensuite tu attends
J'ai toujours réussi à apparaître chaque fois que j'ai
besoin d'espoir qu'il ne fonctionne pas
Snipes
le regard dans ses yeux
[Musique]
vous